live local now good evening and thank
you for joining us tonight at 11 o'clock
i'm sasha loftis we now know the names
of two men accused of a shooting in a
home depot of a home depot employee last
week police have arrested antoine
sconiers and tyrell sharp in texas after
officers say they shot the employee at a
store in north las vegas and took off in
a car with california plates madison
kimbrough spoke with people who normally
shop at the store she joins us live with
their reaction tonight madison
we spoke to several frequent shoppers
here at this home depot all of which
knew about the shooting that took place
here last monday many still in shock
over the situation
you hear it happening at a walmart or
something like that where you have so
many people that influx on it but home
depot i mean come on last monday chaos
erupted at the home depot off craig and
martin luther king boulevard when two
men got into an altercation with a home
depot employee and opened fire shooting
the male employee the suspects pictured
here have been identified as antoine
sconiers and tyrell sharp they are now
in custody after being arrested in texas
nlvpd released this statement saying
quote the suspects from the home depot
shooting on monday were both arrested in
texas by the fort worth police
department on friday due to local
charges in texas it's unknown when they
will be extradited back to nevada
terrell horton lives in the area he and
others say for something like this to
happen so close to home is unsettling
it's kind of scary because i think that
now we can say that crime is happening
everywhere and it's just like everywhere
you go it makes you think about the
safety of you and your family and just
staying in las vegas in general i've
been in this home depot i come here
regularly i mean sometimes just to walk
around in the store
so i would hate to have been here when
something like that's happening with
sconiers and sharp now in custody
frequent shopper ennis wesley says it
brings him a sense of relief to know
that they've been caught as far as them
catching
the the perpetrators that's great that
gives people a lot of
assurance that the law enforcement is
doing what they're doing and and put
your nerves at ease
and as for the home depot employee who
was shot he is recovering in the
hospital reporting live madison
kimbrough live local now
madison thank you matt